should i do more on patreon so today I
have a question for you guys that I'm
hoping you can help answer for me I've
seen a lot of youtubers having some
success with patreon and if you guys
don't know patreon it's a way to support
and contribute to YouTube creators who
then provide some bonuses and activities
and special videos or special access to
things for the people who are supporting
them through their patreon campaigns I
do a little bit on patreon i have a link
it's in the description below you can
check it out but i'm wondering one if i
should be doing more on patreon and to
what kind of exclusive bonuses access
videos would you guys want to see i'm
wondering what tips the point for you so
patreon you're basically paying a fee
youtube it's a monthly donation to the
Creator that you're supporting and
obviously a lot of the stuff that is on
YouTube is totally free and I'm
wondering what what would need to happen
to spread that gap right to say okay I'm
going to support this YouTube creator
and I'm going to I'm going to spend five
bucks a month ten bucks a month to
support that channel what would I have
to provide to you to make that make
sense for you that's what I'm really
curious to find out so I love your
feedback and support let me know what
you think or or if you say nothing
because all i want is the free stuff
that's cool too but all of that feedback
are really value and i'm trying to make
that decision internally to see if i
should be investing more of my time
there or not so i really appreciate your
feedback leave in the comments below
both your thoughts on it and if there's
any experience you've had using patreon
or any other successful campaigns you've
seen that might be worth modeling I
really appreciate those suggestions
leave in the comments thank you guys so
much team to believe I don't see you
soon